herzlich willkommen zur letzten heute
show des jahres meine damen und herren
und natürlich traditionen müssen
gepflegt werden zur verleihung des
goldenen vollpfosten
2021 am ende eines spannenden wahl
jahres mit ganz bitteren ausgang für die
union cdu und csu in der opposition dass
ich das noch erleben darf er muss und
dann setzt man sie im bundestag auch
noch neben die afg eine demütigung jagd
wirklich die nächste aber jetzt freuen
kommt die wende mit dem neuen cdu chef
friedrich merz wird vorsitzender seit
heute unser vorzeitiges
weihnachtsgeschenk
ja gut als ehrlicherweise muss ich zu
ihm diese sendung wurde aus ihrer sicht
schon gestern aufgezeichnet also weiß
ich gar nicht ob merz wirklich im ersten
anlauf gewonnen hat aber sonst gewinnt
hat im 2 was mich immer mal
interessieren würde was macht so eine
union ist eigentlich den ganzen tag wir
werden jede kilowattstunde windenergie
10 wir werden jedes kilo müll zählen wir
werden jeden meter stromleitungen zählen
wir werden jeden kilometer bahntrasse
zählen und das wird unsere politik sein
oh okay die union zählt ab jetzt muss
auch einer machen sie zählen die
stromleitung kilometer die sie 16 jahre
lang selber vergessen haben zu bauen
immerhin mit friedrich merz krieg der
verein endlich wieder profil denn der
nächste unions kanzlerkandidat das ist
sicher der kommt garantiert aus dem
sauerland logisch allerdings macht man
es ihm hier in berlin so schwer wie
möglich die unionsfraktion hat gerade
die posten die überhaupt noch zu
vergeben sind ans alte establishment der
merkel jahre verteilt julia klöckner
leitet die arbeitsgruppe wirtschaft
carlitscheck die ag tourismus jens spahn
ist vize fraktionschef kein einziger
relevanter posten für menschen unter 40
geht so neuanfang cdu ihr habt doch top
nachwuchskräfte wie philipp am tor zum
beispiel wie die jungen wähler chicks um
den finger wickeln vorhin hat mir da
haben wir zu mir gesagt hat sie gesagt
herr abenteuer sie mag ich sie hatten
gutes wetter mitgebracht aber da habe
ich gesagt also alles kann ich jetzt
auch nicht liefern also
alle direkten sprung ok am tor ist
vielleicht auch kein gutes beispiel
fällt mir gerade einen seit dieser
augustus intelligence sache überhaupt
ist das mit dem korruptions geruch der
eigentliche grund für den niedergang der
union manche glauben bis heute es sei
dieser moment gewesen sie wissen schon
dieser momente sie reingeritten hat also
armins legendäres gegen im aartal
während im vordergrund der bundes
spricht aber das ist eine wahrnehmungs
verzerrung der skandal um die masken
deals war natürlich im vergleich viel
verheerender so viel verheerender
mindestens drei unions abgeordnete haben
sich bereichert an der pandemie wasser
weise vor gericht ungestraft bleibt weil
das entsprechende anti korruptionsgesetz
eben leider ein placebo paragraf ist so
daran sollte die union mal arbeiten
statt über armin laschet zu lästern da
ist auch armin oder erwin
armin
laschet und achim laschet geplant lasche
doch entschlossen gegen martin laschet
gegen achim laschet guten armin guten
abend friedrich merz
guten abend der
guten armee in dem 66-jährigen gesicht
der cdu zukunft friedrich merz natürlich
war der historische absturz der union in
diesem jahr eine gemeinschaftsproduktion
meine sowas schaffst du nur im team und
doch fragt wenn man darüber nachdenkt
ein mann einmal mehr heraus markus söder
heute abend unser erster preisträger bei
der verleihung des goldenen vollpfosten
slow datiert valerie niehaus
armin laschet hat einmal gesagt hinter
jedem erfolglosen kleinen mann der eine
war versammelt steht immer auch ein
großer kräftiger mann der ihn ab sagt
markus söder diese bajuwarische monolith
ist nach der niederlage gegen laschet im
kandidaten duell wirklich bis 1 sein
absolutes mitgegangen und hat jeden tag
einfach alles gegeben um ein sieg der
union bei der bundestagswahl zu
verhindern und wenn sie sich immer noch
fragen warum zum henker hat er das
gemacht weil erst kann weil es ihm
freude macht selbst eine tolle karriere
haben gut und schön aber wie viel
befriedigender ist dass die karriere von
anderen zu verhindern
der weiß-blaue ring wir helfen den
politischen opfern von markus söder ich
war der ministerpräsident die leute mir
alles genommen heute noch nicht gross
spielte ihr müsst mich nicht vor fremden
person gebündelt das ist ein hinter
der weiß-blaue ring schauen wir nicht
weg
söder denkt nicht in kategorien wie
schuld verantwortung oder eigene fehler
weil sein kopf übervoll ist mit
ehrlicher begeisterung für sich selbst
um darauf zu kommen genügt ein kurzer
blick auf seinen tik tok kanal hier das
ist von ihm nicht von uns
[Musik]
wer braucht fans wenn er selber sein
größter fan ist und so gibt söder
täglich mindestens fünf
pressekonferenzen und erklärt dem rest
des landes wie corona management geht
mutiger move angesichts der
katastrophalen corona bilanz in bayern
wenn ich so darüber nachdenke eigentlich
gab es im letzten jahr nur einen
einzigen satz von söder über den ich
mich nicht aufgeregt habe streuobst
selber hat eine hohe emotionale
wirtschaftliche und ökologische
bedeutung
da stimmte fast alles die heute-show
verleiht markus söder
nein keinen goldenen pfosten zu viel der
ehre nein von uns gibt's diese tolle
urkunde markus söder hatte am
kanzlerkandidaten wettbewerb
teilgenommen und einen hervorragenden
zweiten platz hinter armin laschet
belegt herzlichen glückwunsch
er hatte im kinderzimmer ein plakat von
strauß ferry vor drei jahren im asyl
touristen raus wer träumte von dem
weltraumbahnhof in bavaria und wermut
trotz intrigen kein kanzlerkandidat im
karneval sagt bei uns wer er wirklich
ist
auch nur verkleidung und
populismus
die anderen sind alle so wie blöd
kein wunder
die sämtlich markus zu
den sieht man abends in der talkshow
morgens dann beinahe pk und
zwischendurch auf instagram einen baum
um
bei dem steg die inzidenz in letzter
zeit so sehr
da konnte er auch nichts dafür das lag
am grenzverkehr macht jemand einen
fehler
das passiert ja überall
dann weiß inzwischen jeder es war auf
keinen fall markus ziener
die anderen sind alle so viel blöder
wenn alle welt
markus l
dann wäre die welt perfekt und so viel
schöner
der chef von allem
mark ist
und die karten
und in jedem raum hängt gut sichtbar ein
kreuz
[Musik]
die haben gesagt ich soll meinen
lieblings witz erzählt es mache ich
gerne also kommen ein pferd chef base
und der papst in eine bar sagt der
barkeeper
abonniere endlich den zwei takten heute
schon kanal also geht doch